using the concept we saw in the previous
video let's see how we plot the length
root 2 on a number line
so let's plot it on this number line we
need to make a right triangle with one
unit as the base let or a be the base of
that triangle we also want its height to
be one unit long let's draw the height a
be like this we just drew a be equal to
one unit perpendicular to Oh a both
these lengths equal one unit now all we
have to do is join OB like this let's
analyze the figure we have Oh a equal to
one unit and a be equal to one unit
using the Pythagoras theorem we have OB
squared equal to Oh a squared plus a B
squared that would equal 1 squared plus
1 squared which is 2 taking the square
root on both sides we get OB equal to
root 2 units this length here will be
root 2 units we just need this length
here on the number line to do that we
keep the vertex of the compass here and
with length OB cut an arc on the number
line let's call this point C this green
length OC will equal this length since
the other radii of the same circle
hence length OC is also equal to root 2
and if we need minus root 2 then we cut
the same arc on the other side of o
let's quickly see how we can actually
construct it let o a be one unit long
then we take a protractor make a
90-degree mark and join that point to a
then on the compass we take the length
of one unit and Mark it on this line to
get a B as one unit and then we join OB
this length OB is root two units and
that is the length we need on the number
line so we keep the compass on point O
take length OB and cut an arc like this
that gives us length OC as root 2 units